fait yacine je pense que tu restes sur
quelque chose d'avant quand tu dis ok
c'est marine mais elle s'appelle le pen
attention ce n'est pas son père comme
toi tu tues épaté par an en fait on
n'est pas pareil et c'est bien pour ça
qu'elle a un peu coupé avec son père
parce que lui c'était lui elle sait
quelque chose d'autre tu vois que quand
tu la regardes que quand tu l'écoutent
elle propose vraiment quelque chose elle
a travaillé elle a une forme de
bienveillance
elle a une forme de 15 ans abattu
là elle est en train de faire une macro
et vox liste donc les trucs je te défie
aujourd'hui elle est
aujourd'hui l'argent ont le droit de
voter qui la potée mais absolument
jallet à droite avec quelqu'un d'autre
qu emmanuel macron qui a fait son temps
puisqu'il a fait cinq ans il avait 5 ans
pour nous montrer ce qui pouvait faire
aujourd'hui à la sortie le bilan c'est
que plus de 60% des français ne veulent
pas reconduire et pourtant les gens
n'osent pas parce qu'il y a des gens
comme toi qui disent surtout pas
l'extrait moi non plus que vous et moi
je sais ce que vous dites de la tribune
le rassemblement national elle a bien
changé parce que tout le monde peut
évoluent donc j'étais ok ce que vous
dites que tu étais de la tribune des
sportifs qu'ils ont fait aujourd'hui
taux plein de sortie qui ont dit tout
sauf marine le pen moi je sois tu
réponds à sa rue neuve cambrésis une
présidente femmes la revois la une une
présidente femme j'aimerais bien voilà
une maman des français quelqu'un qui
rassemble qui protège avec une
sensibilité de femme on sait très bien
que les hommes il parle beaucoup ils
font pas tout le temps on sait bien que
les femmes c'est des mamans c'est une
maman qui fait des choses et les femmes
honteux des femmes les femmes et la raie
manta meyssan est sûre
tu as été miss france oui parce que moi
aussi en aurez accès
l'idée que la miss france représente une
partie des français et c'est à dire ne
tourne le dos aux autres moi je pense
que tu dois comprendre qu' on est un
pays qui n'est pas en accord
c'est pas grave jusqu'à présent le
faisait dans un territoire qui était
pour le coup respectueux je te dis juste
je vous dis sans qui veulent voter
extrême droite ya des gens qui votent
extrême droite je te le dis juste
amicalement puisque on se connaît tu ne
peux pas dire à des gens que marine le
pen c'est la mère de la france est à
dire à des gens que marine le pen c'est
le diable alors je t'ai pas viable parce
que je te dis mais tu es en train de
donner je te le dis pour les gens le
droit des gens aujourd'hui ils profitent
de ce no man's land en ce moment pour se
dire l'extrême droite c'est normal il ya
six ans mais ça mais alors si je
défile aussi
voit que marine le pen a déjà
ses voyelles dit qu'elle aime les
animaux réclament la nature moi ça me
met elle est humaine alors je l'attrapé
quand même qui ont le plus progressé
sont des chats
si je me présente je vais acheter des
chars